today we're gonna explain the full
backstory of all for one
the former overlord of Japan's
underworld and the most deadly potato
the world has ever seen
but before we begin don't forget to sub
to the channel as I think we can hit
50,000 subscribers sometime this month
but without further ado let's get into
the video so all for one was born during
the first generation of quark users when
society was in a complete state of chaos
and hadn't yet come to terms with the
idea of superhumans now at that time
people without quirks made life pretty
difficult for those with mutations and
as we found out in the manga the woman
who actually created the term quark at
least in this context was killed by anti
quark terrorists basically it was a
scary time to be alive and as it says in
this panel laws became effectively
meaningless and during this period of
confusion a young awful one used this
disorder and chaos to his advantage
as an example there were people who had
quirks who didn't want them like this
guy and then there were others who
wanted quirks but didn't have them now
the nature of all-4-one meant now his
power could satisfy the needs of both
groups as he could both steal quarks and
grant quarks by taking power from some
and giving it to others he was able to
accrue an army of loyal servants looking
at these two guys specifically after all
one had swapped their quirks they even
say to him that if he was ever in need
they would come running to help him and
in a completely different example there
was a gang of quark users attacking
people who work worklist until all for
once stepped in and even the playing
field by taking away the gangs powers in
this panel he says that he would give
anyone whatever they wanted as long as
they agreed to join him but this was
just the beginning of his rise to power
as he gathered more and more followers
they began to commit evil acts on his
behalf without him even needing to ask
them the manga tells us of an incident
in which a gang of quark users refused
to accept his new world order and as a
result all the ones followers took the
initiative and blew up the gangs hideout
killing everyone inside his followers
did this not because they were told to
do it but because the existence of this
gang was a threat to all one's ideals he
had genuinely built up an army of people
who bought into his ideas and would do
anything to help him giganto Maki
is another example of this as he would
go out and kidnap people with powerful
quirks even heroes in Chapter 144
giganto machia was looking for the
spring a hero agency and then at the
battle at Kamino we see Wolfe one with
the quirk known as spring-like limbs
coincidence I think not
however despite amassing such a devoted
following
all-4-one had a little brother who was
strongly opposed to everything that was
going on now
the brother believed that quirk
shouldn't be used for personal gain and
I all for one was manipulating people
and exploiting their weaknesses and just
a little bit of trivia for you their
family name is sugar Aki so because this
brother was his only family
all-4-one still loved him and did
everything he could to make his brother
join his army essentially despite that
his brother kept refusing time and time
again the guy even went on hunger strike
and refused to eat was wolf one keeping
him locked up in this room or something
my guess is probably yeah anyway the
youngest sugar Aki was a fan of a
certain comic book and all one remarked
how his rise to power was exactly like
the demon lord from that old comic book
now his brother then said to him that
the demon did conquer the world but that
the hero who was fighting for justice
managed to struggle past his pain and
defeat the villain in the end it was at
that moment that all f---one uttered
this ultimate mic drop line in which he
says that fantasy has become reality but
that reality doesn't follow the old
playbook yeah he just flamed him right
there he then forcibly gave his brother
a stockpile ink work and he did this to
make him submit in much the same way
that other people who he gave quirks to
would submit to him and become his loyal
followers and he specifically chose the
stockpiling power because his brother's
frail body would be able to handle it as
he stockpiling ability had already been
built up yet and this is where we get
the ultimate plot twist which I'm sure
most of you watching this already know
what this is gonna be his brother did
actually have a quirk which a son
someone may or may not have told him
about check out my Batgirl Theory video
if you want to know more about that it
turns out that the brother had a secret
quirk that allowed him to pass on quirks
whereas beforehand everyone thought he
was completely Quercus this transferring
ability was then fused with the
stockpiling quirk as it says here the
brother was defeated and chose to pass
on the power in the hope that one
you could be strong enough to stop his
older brother which is the perfect time
to mention that all f---one acquired an
age defying quirk and was basically
going to live forever until someone
actually went out of their way to kill
him now over the years all-4-one became
obsessed with one-for-all almost like a
video game
he sought to destroy anyone who
possessed the power and also went around
crushing the strong this allowed him to
become the unrivaled symbol of evil and
take over the underworld of Japan all my
said the or1 had such a degree of power
and control over Japan that it would be
hard to even comprehend it today
one by one he crushed each of the
following successes of one for all with
absolute ease but he was unable to
actually steal the quark because it can
only be passed on when the user wants it
to be but still I mean look at these
guys they have been battered they have
been bruised they've had their arms
blown off like it's it's not been a good
time for them now doctor Jaco is another
one of all four ones faithful servants
over the years and his real name is
actually dr. garage by the way kind of a
play on the name's Chigurh aki I guess
now dr. garage said that out of
everything all for once sought to
possess one flaw was the one power that
didn't behave in the way he wanted so I
think it's pretty clear that he didn't
create this power on purpose as I think
some people have theorized in the past
so after killing all these ones for all
users he finally gets to the seventh
Nana's shamora
and yeah he still kills her as well but
this time things go a bit differently
afterwards so off one had a few more
years of dominance before all my came to
the forefront and began to defeat all
for one's allies one by one and prior to
them having a massive battle for the
ages big shigaraki who is all for one
took it upon himself to find the
grandchild of Nana shamora and take him
under his wing and even gave him his
family name this child would then grow
up to be Tamara Suga rocky who is the
primary antagonist of my hero academia
and during the battle at Kamino all one
did admit to all my that the only reason
he did this was to one day break all my
spirit and he also engineered encounters
between both almighty and Shigure Aki
you gotta rate this guy's commitment to
the bit because it was a long way to see
that drug payoff
he raised Tamara shigaraki to become a
successor and he wanted him to unify
people who were riled up by stains
ideology in much the same way that he
wants unified those people who were lost
in a chaotic society all-4-one then came
face to face with prime almighty and the
two had a battle that left his head
completely crushed it was believed that
he had died and to be honest he I mean
he probably should have but dr. groggy
who was definitely all for ones most
loyal follower maybe second to garganta
macchia dr. garage to save him the
doctor revealed that he had offered all
for one his technology all the different
no moves including the high ends and
even his life basically he's willing to
do anything for this man
so using his crazy Frankenstein type
science he managed to salvage all for
one and essentially bring him back to
life
or at least stop him from dying but in a
way this was a good thing as it allowed
to Muruga rocky to come to the forefront
and lead the league of villains and
whilst the doctor said in this panel
that he believed that the League of
villains would run much smoother if Alf
warmer still in charge I think by this
point all-4-one had developed a genuine
love for shigaraki and actually wanted
him to take over Hawk says that the
league's ultimate goal is the second
coming of all-4-one but they aren't
talking about this all for one they're
talking about the next or for one it is
my firm belief that shigga rocky will
one day receive the Olfa one quirk that
much i am a hundred percent sir enough
but yeah guys that was everything we
know about all f---one up until the
battle at Kamino and we all know what
happened there as of making this video
all-4-one is still in a prison cell and
but he definitely won't be staying there
forever I can tell you that much
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and help me reach my goal of 50,000
subscribers it would mean a lot
peace out
you